نقعد معكم الى متابعه جلسه تداع حكومه
بنيمنهور لليومين القانونيه امام الكنيست
نعمل معا
لتحقيق العصر الذهبي لاسرائيل
وهذا ما يجب ان نواصل ان نفعله
لمصلحه كل افراد الشعب الاسرائيلي
[تصفيق]
المتحدث ان يتوقف
المجلس عن التصفيق شهرته وكانني ميسي
اسمحوا لي ان اقول بدعه كلمات
تنبعه من القلب
هذه المره السادسه
[موسيقى]
لو سمحتم لو سمحتم
[تصفيق]
زويبا
اراسها
ونطالب بثقه الكنيست
انا الحسه بمهامه
جدي ربي ايه بالكوفسكي نتنياهو
و ايضا
نتنياهو اخي الذي
سقط في الحرب
قوه القياده
اخذها منكم
واخذ من رؤيتكم وايضا لاسرتي ولزوجتي ساره
الى جانبي دوما
ولكم
احبائي هذه فرصه لي ان اشكركم انتم
القوه لحياتي واحبكم كثيرا
الاسباني الاسباني
[تصفيق]
في مقر الكنيست من المقرر يؤدي الى سريعه
وجميله القسم امام اعضاء الكلسات
الاسرائيلي بعد ان تمكنوا من تشكيل حكومته
وبعد ان اضاف مؤخرا وزير وزير الدفاع
نتنياهو في كلمته امام اعضاء الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي قال بان حكومه وستعمل على
توقيع اتفاقيات السلام مع دول المنطقه
وان اسرائيل ست تحافظ على التفوق العسكري
وانا استعمل على احباط مساعي ايران
لامتلاك سلاح نووي ان ذلك الامر هو في
مقدمه اولويات الحكومه
حنين
الرئيس بن جميل
وزير التكنولوجيا والعلوم
وزيره التعليم وزير التعليم وزير الامن
القومي
لو سمحتم لو سمحتم
ان مكتب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صارت الكلابه السياقه
اشهر الاجتماعيات
ووزير الاسكان
ووزير الزراعه والتنميه
سوريا
ووزير
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه هذه وزاره جديده
يمثلها سفيرنا السابق في واشنطن رونبر
ووزير الصحه
[موسيقى]
وزير ايليكون
خارجيه وزير الطاقه
نائب رئيس الوزراء ووزير الداء العدل
ووزير الاستخبارات
ووزير الشؤون الدينيه من خلال
ووزير الاجتماعيه
القوميه ووزير
البيئه ايفل
ووزر
والدفاع سيكون مسؤول عن التنسيق تنسيق
الشؤون
في منطقه السامره ويبكيش مازير التعليم
وزير الاتصالات
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم
ساره
والحكومه
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
رئيس اكبر حزب ليس موجود في التالف
رقص رقص
الزملاء العزاء
ارجو منكم
مراعات الهدوء
شكرا لك شكرا لكم الزملاء الاعزاء
النا حلفان يمين الحكومه
يضعوا حجره اساس
وقدمنا
هذه العمليه الانتقاليه لحكومه جديده
فالكنيست والمواطنين الاسرائيليين يجب ان
يقدم لهم كل ما يحقق مصلحه الامه احترامنا
لهذه
الحكوماء ود ان اعطيكم تقرير عن لما قامت
به الحكومه السابقه التي راسها نبتالي بنت
وتحت رئاسه من اجل
اي محاوله لاعاده كتابه التاريخ ود ان
اوضح بعض الامور الانجازات الحكومه
السابقه
اول المهم
هو
الحيله دون
تعادل قوه ايران وانا اتفق معه في ذلك
فحكوماتنا تمكنت من وقف اعاده توقيع
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران فقط
والحرس الثوري لم يرفع اسمهم من قائمه
الجماعات الارهابيه والملفات
الموجوده في الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه لم تغلق بعد
التوقيع الاعلان
الذي تضمن اتفاق مبادئ على ان لاسرائيل
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها ووقف ايران من
التحول الى دوله نوويه وهذا
شمل التزام امريكي للتعاون الاقتصادي وهو
على صعيد غير مسبوق وكذلك هناك قائمه
طويله من الامور المعروفه وغير المعروفه
التي انجزناها التي اوقفت ايران عن نموها
همم لتصبح قوه كبيره
واضعفناها ايضا في سوريا وغير ذلك
كما اذن
سددنا المشاريع الامنيه التي كانت
متجاهله سابقا وقد اعيد تفعيل بعض
المشاريع التي كانت معطله ااا
ايضا حوار المكثف مع الجانب الامريكي ومن
خلال تقويه
الاسرائيليه
وكذلك
تعاون الامريكي من خلال وجود ال همم
السفاره الامريكيه
في
القدس
وبالتالي لا يوجد اي فيتو امريكا ضد اي
عمل اسرائيلي ولا
نسمح باي تحقيق بهويه الضباط
ثمن
الامارات
والبحرين
ونواصل مباحثات
في جلسه الكنيسه الاسرائيليه الجلسه
المخصصه للمصادقه على تشكيل الحكوميه
الجديده برئاسه بنيامين نتانيا
نتنياهو قد واجه اعتراض داخل الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي اثناء قراءه او قراءته لاسماء
اعضاء حكومته الجديده في خطابه امام
الكنيست قال انه سيعمل على توقيع اتفاقيه
سلام الجديده مع الدول
وان حكومته ستحافظ على التفوق العسكريه
الاسرائيلي ايضا في المنطقه
والنساء ايضا نستعمل على احباط مساء ايران
لامتلاك سلاح الن وان ذلك في مقدمه همم
اولويات حكومه